[Music]
what do you think this is a candle maybe
a sausage or a type of Snickers bar well
it's actually a snack called Chella and
it's
[Music]
delicious georell are traditional
Georgian sweets that have been made for
thousands of years rich in calories and
natural sugars they're kind of like the
original energy bar if stored properly
they can last up to a year making them
ideal for long
Journeys so ideal it's thought that
Georgian soldiers once relied on them
for traveling long distances and for
nourishment before
battle
foreign
foree
[Music]
for
fore forign
fore fore
[Music]
spee
[Laughter]
chuch Kellers taste sweet and have a
soft elastic consistency with a crumbly
Center over the years Chella has
traveled across borders Regional
versions exist across Europe the
Caucasus and the Middle
[Music]
East
fore
speee
spe
speeech
fore